we're told that the nth partial sum of
the series from N equals one to infinity
of a sub n is given by and so the sum of
the first n terms is N squared plus 1
over n plus 1 and they want us to figure
out what is the actual seventh term and
like always pause this video and see if
you can figure it out on your own before
we work through it together alright so
one way to think about it is a sub seven
let's think about how that relates to
different sums so if we have a sub 1
plus a sub two I'll just go all the way
a sub a sub 3 plus a sub four plus a sub
five + a sub six plus a sub seven so if
I were to sum all of these things
together that this entire sum that would
be S sub seven and if I wanted to figure
out a sub seven well I could subtract
from that I could subtract out the sum
of the first six terms so I could sum I
could subtract out S sub I could
subtract out S sub six so once again
what am i doing here what is my strategy
I know the formula for the sum of the
first n terms I can use that to say okay
I can figure out the sum of the first
seven terms that's going to be the sum
of all of these and then I can use that
same formula to figure out the sum of
the first six terms and the difference
between the two well that's going to be
our a sub seven so another way of saying
what I just said is that a sub seven is
going to be the sum of the first seven
terms minus the sum of the first six
terms some of the sixth for the sum of
the first six terms and if you are doing
this problem on your own you wouldn't
have to write it out this way I just
wrote it out this way hopefully making
this statement a little bit more
intuitive well what is what are what is
this going to be well S sub seven the
sum of the first seven terms we just
whatever we CNN we replace it with a
seven so it's going to be seven squared
plus one over seven plus one and from
that we are going to subtract S sub six
the sum of the first six terms well
that's going to be
six squared plus one or six plus one
over six plus one and from here we just
have to do a little bit of arithmetic so
this is going to be let's see seven
squared plus one
this is 49 plus 1 so that is 50 over 8
and this is 6 squared plus one that is
36 plus one that's 37 over seven so
let's see we want to find a common
denominator between 8 & 7 that would be
56 so this is going to be something over
56 something over 56 minus something
else over 56 minus something else over
56 now to go from 8 to 56 I multiply by
7 so I need to multiply the numerator by
7 as well 50 times 7 is 350 and then
this second fraction I multiply the
denominator by 8 to get 256 so after
multiply 37 times 8 and see 37 times 8
is going to be 240 plus 56
so that is 296 296 and so this is going
to be equal to so I have a denominator
of 56 350 minus 296 is 54 so it's 54 56
and if we wanted to reduce this a little
bit before we rewrite it maybe in a
simpler form we're not really making us
where it's we're rewriting the same
value this would be seek we read it as
27 over 28 27 28 and let's see is that
about yep that's about as as simplified
as we can get but there you go that's
what a sub 7 is it's 27 28 the
difference between the sum of the first
7 terms and the sum of the first six
terms